The joe rogan experience,
the wonder woman one.
You know what drives me crazy,
but all this wonder woman shit,
it's men who get upset at wonder woman.
It's the same thing that drives me crazy about this black panther movie.
What drives me crazy about this black panther movie is people getting upset
about this Black Panther movie,
but on both sides,
first of all,
white people making a big deal.
I like,
oh great,
oh,
it's all black people like,
well,
it shouldn't just be all good people.
Like of course this is the way the story was and this is the way they want to
promote it.
Why do you care?
Like it doesn't,
I don't care.
But then it goes the other way and I do care where I've seen crazy liberal
psychos and there were white people in fact saying,
white people stay the fuck out of the theater while uh,
this a while Black Panther is out,
don't steal their joy with your white privilege.
Oh my God,
I literally saw it.
Something along those lines.
I saw a couple of those,
one of them where a woman was asking when it was appropriate to see it.
She and she didn't,
she didn't want to ruin it with her whiteness.
She was totally serious,
totally serious.
And those people were real people and they think that that's,
that makes sense.
Like God dammit.
When,
when shaft was out,
do you think white people couldn't go see shaft when blade came out in
[inaudible] 98 did white people stay home?
Like what are we doing?
Are we more divided now than we ever were before?
We so silly that you can't,
I want to go see Black Panther cause I like fucking superhero movies and it
looks cool.
The fact that anybody would give a shit one way or the other.
I guess if you're a black kid or a black guy who was like,
hey this gives all of us hope that there's more opportunity for movies to be
made like that,
that people aren't really racist and they can embrace a black superhero the same
way they can embrace the Hawk or Thor.
If the movie's really good and I hope the movie is really good and I hope that's
exactly what happens.
But how the fuck did it change so much from one blade was around cause when
blade was around,
dude,
nobody even thought about the fact that it was a black superhero movie.
I mean I guess some people did,
but the emphasis with the fact that Wesley fucking snipes was blade and it
looked good and he was doing karate and chop and vampires up with swords and
shit.
It was a fucking bad ass movie.
That movie was super successful.
They did two sequels.
So like what's changed?
How the fuck is it changed from then until now?
Why is now,
why is it a big deer?
If there's a black superhero,
but it wasn't a big deal then like are we deteriorating or is it just more noise
because of social media?
Do you get a more distorted sense of how the country actually feels?
Because the people that are more inclined to chime in regularly and vehemently
are oftentimes not the ones who are calculated.
You know,
assessing thinkers,
they're maybe a little bit more aggressive shooting off the,
so what you're getting is not an accurate representation of how people feel,
but then you start defending it as if it is accurate.
And so then people start telling white people to stay the fuck home.
Now you've got craziness and you've got craziness because of the fringe,
the fringe on both sides,
but in the middle.
Most people like,
I hope it's a cool movie.
Yeah.
Uh,
could you imagine if you had a friend and you were going to,
you want to go see a,
that Black Panther movie?
Nah Man.
Fucking these uppity black dudes just really getting into this movie too much.
You'd be like,
what you would,
you would immediately stop hanging out with that guy and you'd probably tell all
of us,
he'd be like,
you won't know what that fucking guy said.
And we'd be like,
what the call?
You know,
all that stuff is disgusting.
All of it's disgusting.
It's disgusting on both sides.
It's like anytime you're prejudice against white people or even d critical about
yourself being white,
that you should stay the fuck away from places.
That is crazy.
Not talking about intruding on cultural rituals.
We're talking about an awesome movie.
Everybody who can buy tickets,
you buy a ticket,
it will make the movie more successful.
You want giant opening weekends.
If you really loved this movie and you want movies like this to be successful,
you should be promoting it for everybody.
Why people?
Black people,
Asian people who gives a fuck cause see the superhero movie?
It's going to be fun.
He's got a pendant.
It turns into a fucking bulletproof outfit and he fucks people up.
You shoot him,
he gets more powerful.
It's fun.
Go Watch.
Like who gives a shit?
If it's,
I get the people that take pride in it,
they feel like something's happening for them that it's a black guy,
but the people that are white than have an issue with it.
Oh my God,
you've got to let some shit go.
You just gotta let the noise go by.
Don't let it bounce around inside your head and come up with a year,
but I'm not ruthless.
Why do I have to good shoved in my face and
everybody's got to meet in the middle.
It's a crazy time.
Everybody's got to meet in the middle.
There's way less tension and a conflict then as being verbalized.
That's what I think.
I think if people just realize that a lot of the shit that we're clean too has
just some ways we've been thinking and behaving for a long time and then we can
all just fucking communicate with each other just a little bit better.
I just don't think,
I don't think that racism has gotten worse.
I think it absolutely has gotten worse in some places.
I think there's places where racism exists.
And I think those,
I think when you have young kids that are raised with racism and family members
that are raised at racism and a community that embraces racism,
which has existed in the past,
you know,
and we don't even have to talk about today,
but in the past it was most certainly really racist neighbor at the tally
neighborhoods in New York where black people moved in,
they were treated terribly and horrible shit happened a lot of times they
weren't even allowed to move in,
in the first place.
And there's always been stuff like that.
Um,
so if there's always been stuff like that,
it's a natural human inclination that we have to iron out.
We can't just eliminate it by making it illegal or eliminate it by prosecuting
people.
We have to figure out why people think like that to scary way to think.
Scary to that.
Any one speed.
Look,
first of all,
all of us,
and almost anyone listening to this in comparison to someone like Elon Musk is
basically a chimp.
Okay,
so you want to be racist.
You should be racist about against this African guy that's smarter than
everybody.
Like what do you,
that's a real African guy from South Africa.
Ilan mosque.
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
Um,
he's a real African American.
Yeah.
Like legitimately,
but obviously there's different sheen,
black,
African and I believe it was the Dutch that originally settled that area,
you know,
and that's,
he's the descendants of those people.
But my point is like we're all dumb asses compared to that guy.
So it's top kit and I'll uppity about why people,
you know,
have a better GPA is and whatever other race you're comparing us to cause your
stupid yeah.
Compared to that one African dude.
Like you're dumb for sure.
For sure.
Like there's no way you're,
your vote should count more than his.
Yeah.
Right.
Mine personally are most anybody's years,
personally,
I don't know.
This idea that there's one race is better than the other races.
Fucking stupid.
The people that are really clinging to it usually don't have shit going on.
Other than that.
That's the problem with racism.
It puts people in a camp of winters when they really don't have to do shit to
get into it.
Get into the team,
you know,
the entrance is instantaneous.
You just,
Oh,
you're white,
you're in.
You know,
that's ridiculous.
That's a ridiculous team.
That's the problem.
That's one of the main problems with re with the ridiculous nature of racism,
especially organized racism,
that you just got to take everybody that looks like you.
That's it.
That's all.
Not,
not how they think.
Not what they've read.
Not the life experiences,
not how you feel when you're hanging around with them.
Not how they make you laugh.
No.
You want to make sure that they have blood from a certain patch of dirt.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
It's so stupid.
And they moved the goalpost too,
cause I'm a white guy now.
But when my grandparents came here,
they were dirty guineas.
Yeah.
You know,
they were,
um,
they were thought of the way a lot of people think about Mexicans,
you know,
same kind of thing.
No,
that's changed now.
The Italians are full on white.
Yup.
Totally.
They almost lost our distinction with Jersey shore.
We almost lost it.
Yeah.
We came real close to losing it.
Okay.